[Music]
there should be that was that I think
Bruce the cue card guy just walked in
front of the camera
sorry zoning okay
walked in front of the camera jeepers
how long have you been a cue card guy
six years six years and you still don't
know how to duck under a camera shot I
said I'm sorry six years more like he's
been in the business for six minutes
stop it Conan oh poor little Brucie
we'll see he doesn't like it we're
cutting teachers head I'm getting upset
you wouldn't like me when I get upset by
bruised yeah wow what a thin-skinned
weirdo there
do you feel kind of bad though maybe we
should go backstage and see if he's okay
[Music]
no cheese please oh my god ladies and
gentlemen Incredible Hulk no me not Hulk
Hulk intellectual property of Marvel Inc
and Disney all rights reserved
Hulk image trademarked reproduction or
broadcast of Hulk image only permitted
with licensing agreements prohibitively
expensive wait a minute you're green not
green
I am olive with hints of khaki
difference I'm really confused why
aren't you using your own voice normal
speaking voice too much like Hulk
constitute copyright infringement
it smells us all to legal consequences
I have actor to me he sound more like
Cookie Monster okay so you're not Bruce
the cue card guy then oh yeah I've been
here the whole time
that's just my friend he's really
protective
no change from Bruce change from Bruce
to close to Hulk storyline folk story
not protected by copyright law unlawful
use or appropriation above storyline
constitute infringement and subject to
heavy fog okay yeah okay so you're just
a massive semi articulate bodybuilder
who's furious at me for picking on our
two car guy yes
don't read more into it okay well then
what's your name if it's not the Hulk no
Hansard okay
The Incredible Lyle Hanson everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
you